what's going on Rob this is guys and in
this video Batman and Superman are
fighting the anti-batman and it's
amazing so what this does is this
initially opens up with Bruce Wayne
standing half naked in his bedroom
calling Selena Kyle but there's a cool a
couple cool things to talk about here
right so in this conversation that they
have just by nature of the conversation
that they're having in the sense that
she wants to say something he wants to
say something neither of them really say
the thing that they actually want to say
staying in contact and so on and so
forth this all comes off the heels of
Tom King's Batman run now technically
you got Tom King then you had James
tinyon then you had Joshua Williamson I
think but the important thing here is
that during Tom King's Batman run Batman
and Catwoman were going to get married
and it was one of the most anticipated
things in the entirety of his run we
were super excited about it as fans and
then he did when we were all afraid he
was going to do which was pull the rug
out from under it and they never got
married which basically pissed everybody
off and soured everybody to the rest of
Tom King's Batman run and rightfully so
but the thing about this is that they
still have a lot of love for each other
it was really more of the fact that
Bruce Wayne cannot be Batman and have a
life with Catwoman even by his own
admission he says I can't have that kind
of distraction and that was the reason
why they never got together in the first
place it's why they never got married
but the other thing that goes on here is
that Selena Kyle kind of dropped the
idea that somebody out there is
murdering the ultra wealthy within the
city of Gotham now for Selena Kyle this
is kind of a big deal for Batman it's a
Tuesday right just like somebody killing
somebody in Gotham it happens all the
time but he ends up showing up at the
apartment of a guy by the name of Colin
Fitzroy now that name is important not
for the most significant of reasons but
for Bruce Wayne and the reason for this
is because he shows up in this place in
one of the most dope ways ever right so
like literally this guy who's like
holding these people hostage is being
like yelled at by the cops you know and
he was like get away or I'll kill them I
swear to God and then he looks over and
he sees Batman and Batman's like not God
not even close and like immediately
attacks the guy it's dope like it's just
one of the most dope moments ever in a
Batman comic I loved it I was like holy
cow but of course once he takes this guy
out that's what he realizes this guy had
already killed Colin Fitzroy and his
wife and so the result of this is that
Batman immediately takes it to this guy
realizing he's a Hitman he was basically
a Hitman that was presumably bad at his
job and that's why the cops showed up on
the doorstep because he lingered around
for too long but then you transitioned
to the penguin right now the penguin is
not a major player here he's not a main
focal point but he is a catalyst right
he is a very important part of the story
in that way because what the penguin
does is he kind of issues this broadcast
and he simply makes this case insane I
as the penguin have have clawed and
scrapped and worked my way all the way
up to the top right like so many of you
I started out with nothing and now I
have seemingly everything but the ultra
Rich are not like us right like they
were born into wealth they were born
into the lap of luxury they've never had
to work for anything so they don't
understand how hard it is in a lot of
ways the speech of penguin here mirrors
the speech of Bane from The Dark Knight
Rises right like you know going on that
huge tear and talking about how the
police will survive and the powerful
will be ripped from their decadent nests
and passed out into the cold world that
we all know and endure it's very much
that kind of statement and so by feeding
on the fears and the desires of the
people in Gotham to have some measure of
a better life for themselves even if it
means destroying the ultra wealthy in
the process that's exactly what cavapa
does it works in his favor because while
it doesn't necessarily lead to like a
full-on Revolt in Gotham it does get him
the side of the people to a degree now
the other part of this is that Tim Drake
showing up here is Robin meeting with
Bruce Wayne they have this bit of a
conversation and Tim Drake starts saying
things like after you lost everything
you just haven't quite been the same
what he's referring to is the events of
Joker War so Joker war was a phenomenal
story written by James tennan and again
you'll find a link to the Batman
playlist in the comments where you can
get caught up with all of this stuff
because Joker war was great the idea
behind Joker war is it was quite
literally Joker waging a war against
Batman but instead of just like
attacking him the way he normally does
in effect he sees control of Wayne
Enterprises and by dumping all the
personal information of Bruce Wayne out
there into the world revealing his
identity publicly the federal government
seized their assets and so on and so
forth and so in effect Bruce Wayne lost
it all he lost all of his money because
by all standards of measurement
according to the law he was operating as
a vigilante and using his wealth to do
so now had he been locked up the Son of
Sam laws also would have applied so
there were a lot of things that he
simply just couldn't do right there are
things that he that couldn't work in his
favor and he effectively lost everything
and so ever since that story he's slowly
been kind of building himself back up
and trying to get himself back to where
he was it was one of the coolest shifts
like coolest Paradigm shifts in the
entirety of the uh of the the Batman
Mythos and so following this where he
kind of shows up to like this ultra
wealthy event one of the things to know
it's just the name of Bruce Wayne that's
carrying him through and as I understand
it because I'm not Ultra rich but as I
understand it when it comes to ultra
rich people like that the name carries a
lot of weight so even if you don't
necessarily have as much money as you
used to or really even any money at all
you're considered old money and Bruce
Wayne is considered old money right his
family had been around forever they had
a huge fortune that kind of a thing so
his name allows him to sort of get into
places that he otherwise wouldn't be
able able to access and so the result of
this is that when he shows up to this
great big huge Gala he realizes that the
entire event is being put on by the
penguin so while he's putting on the
front face of Bruce Wayne Tim Drake as
Robin is running around trying to figure
out how to neutralize what it is the
Penguin has going on now it's not as
though Bruce Wayne just showed up at the
gala and then realized what was
happening Bruce Wayne ever the detective
realized that with penguin setting up
this Gala he was gonna try to kill all
the ultra wealthy in Gotham in one Fell
Swoop and penguin being as simple as he
is Batman deduced it would likely be gas
it's the most efficient way to kill as
many people as possible and of course
Tim Drake ends up finding the entire
Reservoir where the gas is being held
and so on and so forth and so when
penguin makes his Grand declaration
right while none of you deserve to be
here I welcome you to the gala and I
welcome you to your death he activates
the gases but then nothing happens and
so of course that's when Bruce Wayne
steps up with the mask and then starts
attacking Penguins so on and so forth
and this is when you get this amazing
shift right it's not penguin it's one of
the coolest things it was never the
penguin doing this it was but it wasn't
right right the person standing here is
actually Clayface pretending to be
penguin now one of the things that I
love about what DC's been doing with
Batman's stories recently is they've
been repurposing Clayface instead of him
just kind of being a guy who's running
around pretending to be like some
innocuous person and then committing
some crime that different villains are
using his ability to shapeshift for
their own ends does it turn him or
potentially turn him into like a
henchman some second class villain
that's out there yeah I mean this was
it'd be very very easy to just kind of
Shuffle him off to a character that only
ever appears in a joker story when the
Joker needs him for some purpose but the
idea of them using him in this way is
cool because it presents other amazing
possibilities right even Batman has used
Clayface for this purpose in his own
ends right the old the old Detective
comic stories from DC rebirth focused on
this heavily so again it's really cool
to see this massive shift with Clayface
now of course once this reveal comes
along right you know they realize
penguin's not there at that point it's
we gotta get everybody out of here the
problem with this is that as this
happens one of the henchmen pulls a gun
and shoots Tim break through the neck
and when that happens while Batman's
interrogating Clayface wanting to know
where the penguin is he realizes Robin's
been shot and everything else gets
ignored now so Batman literally grabs
everybody or I'm sorry grabs Robin and
then leaves what's so interesting about
this though is that it also illustrates
the fact that the penguin is not nearly
as dumb as Batman thought he was that
the penguin sure had the gas as like his
main plan right as plan a for killing
all the ultra wealthy here but as a plan
B leaving nothing to chance he also set
it up so the building would collapse
right so that's one of the cool things
that happens here but the other part of
that is that Batman grabbing Robin takes
off but he comes to this realization
just because of what Tim Drake's telling
him that he can't show up with Tim Drake
at the hospital that one he's bleeding
out too much too fast because the bullet
hit an artery so he's bleeding out too
hard in order for Batman to fix it on
his own or for Batman to take him to
Leslie Tompkins the back alley doctor
the Batman uses it doesn't work that way
right there's just too much blood loss
happening and so what Batman has to do
is switch Tim Drake out of his Robin
clothes into like civilian clothes and
then take him to the hospital the other
reason why he took him to this this
hospital is that an interrogating clay
face he realized or at least Clayface
told him where the penguin was and the
Penguin himself is actually dying right
he's literally perishing like that's it
like he's just dying of whatever illness
he has and it's kind of a funny thing
because he says that he has like mercury
poisoning but penguin also has an ace up
his sleeve right he's got this amazing
age because what he says is that no
matter what his Target was he was never
able to destroy Batman now he doesn't
say that he was inspired by the events
of Joker War but given the chronology of
Batman up to this point you have to
believe that he was because one of the
big things about Joker war is it showed
that Batman was not Untouchable that
sometimes the best way to take out
Batman is not by attacking the bat
family Robin and Batgirl and and all
those different characters but is
actually going after Bruce Wayne himself
the things that allow him to be Batman
right kicking the chair out from under
him so to speak and so by doing that
this more or less pushed penguin an
erection or seems to push him in a
direction that taking out Batman
indirectly is the best way to do it and
so knowing he's dying the penguin ends
his own life by calling the nurse while
simultaneously popping a cyanide capsule
and so what it looks like when the nurse
gets in there is that Batman killed the
penguin that's exactly how it looks and
it's amazing it's so it's such a smart
move by Oswald cobblepot I love this
decision I love chip zadarsky's run man
it's some of the most some of the most
amazing creativity that I've seen when
it came to writing Batman in years and
so with Batman basically bailing out
what this does is it activates the
Fail-Safe system now this is one of the
cool things because if you don't know
the history of the Batman Mythos the
purpose and the benefit of Fail-Safe is
kind of lost on you but if you do know
the Batman Mythos it's amazing right so
here's one of the coolest things right
it's one of the best high ends ever of
course Batman Retreats back to the bat
cave tries to catch himself a little bit
of a nap trying to recuperate while
Robin's healing but one of the things
that happens here is you get this
realization that because the world now
believes that Batman had killed the
penguin that it actually kind of worked
against what the penguin was planning
for then in fact because criminals are
afraid of the fact that Batman kills now
crime is lower than it's ever been
that's why I tell you guys Batman
killing villains is probably a good idea
right I mean it's it's you know above a
certain threshold right I mean a guy who
like snatches a purse probably doesn't
deserve to die but the Joker yeah man
yes the Joker needs to be done with all
his living but while Batman's basically
recuperating the Fail-Safe robot emerges
and crushes this guy and that's the
thing it's not even close there's this
point where like Batman goes to like
punch Fail-Safe he's like man son you
better come strong like he immediately
dominates this guy like just dominates
Batman in the most amazing way ever like
it's just it's to the point where Batman
has to just Flee for his life
like that's literally the only thing he
can do is just run like just to run as
fast as he can and even when he starts
talking to Barbara Gordon Oracle and
he's like can you find a way to hack
this thing do you know what this is can
you scan its systems can you give me any
help whatsoever her response is no she's
like the best I can tell you is that the
skin and here suggests a variety of
Robotics including Amazon tech for those
of guys who aren't really familiar with
Amazo Amazo no pun intended was amazing
so Amazo was a robot that had the
ability to duplicate Powers fighting
styles the whole nine yards but of
course with this Amazo Tech being there
that's when Batman realizes it's too
much right like this Fail-Safe is way
too much and in fact when Batman tries
to flee literally failsafe grabs his
cape and pulls him back down to the
ground he's like where are you going
like little grabbing like pulls him back
down the ground like no son you ain't
running for this fight right then the
rest of the just like the rest of the
bat family shows up so you have like
spoiler and you have like all these
characters who show up not even in hell
would you see a massacre like this right
like literally they all come running and
Fail-Safe and he's like all right home
slice and he just dismantles them all he
takes the whole team apart piece by
piece dominating every single person I
mean it's just it's crazy Robin has to
like grab Batman and get him out of
there as fast as he can right like
literally get him away and then like
Fail-Safe come chasing after him like
Nightwing finally catches up to
Fail-Safe and then as soon as Nightwing
shows up Fail-Safe just flies away so
like literally there's nothing these
guys can do like this thing was enough
to dominate Batman and the rest of the
team it's one of the coolest moments out
here now of course failsafe does
eventually come back and when he does
you have Tim Drake you have signal you
have these guys who are like trying to
find a way to defeat him and again he
just crushes them all I mean it's just
it's one of the one of the most amazing
moments where like the bad family is
just readily taken apart and that's why
I say failsafe is awesome man because
none of these guys these guys never had
a chance you know what I mean like you
have like a Batman story and it's like
they're putting up a good fight and the
clouds will part and the planets will
align and then comic book logic will be
used and like they will win but like
that's not what's happening here man
like these guys are fighting their best
and they're getting absolutely crushed
this guy's like the Brawley of the
Batman comics right just like taking
these guys apart with the greatest of
ease and so you switch over to Leslie's
pumpkins in the bat cave who again is
kind of like this sort of Night Nurse
type character that Batman uses whenever
he needs Aid only for her to find out
that like Fail-Safe is there instead of
Batman more so than that what Batman
does is he has this kind of inner
monologue when he gets to a different
location a separate location from the
bat cave itself and what happens is he
tells Tim Drake there's something that I
have to do and I have to do this thing
alone and where Tim Drake kind of begs
and pleads and says no no you gotta let
me help you with this the response of
Batman in his inner monologue is he
wouldn't understand right none of them
would the lengths that I've gone to I've
softened surrounded myself with children
but in my early days God help me in my
early days I went too far Fail-Safe is
familiar but familiar doesn't mean the
same thing when you have a mind that
remembers everything it's an aberration
a fault line running clean across my
memory there's a ticking deep in my head
like a clock Tick Tock so what he's
basically saying here is fail safe
sounds familiar but it doesn't sound
like anything that he's ever created but
he knows he did and so he doesn't really
understand why and so what he ends up
doing is actually kind of getting into
this little bit of a chest and then when
he re-emerges he's a totally different
Batman where he's like I'm the Batman
this is one of the coolest moments
because again this all goes into the
Batman myth though so this is when we
kind of tie back around into all of this
stuff so what this does here is it
basically kind of jumps back a little
bit and it involves a conversation
between Batman and Superman and the
conversation here is the two of them
talking about how Batman was voted out
of the Justice League now the reason why
this conversation is taking place is
because this happens after the events of
Tower of Babel so Tower of Babel was the
story that introduced the Batman
protocols basically what Bruce Wayne had
done in secret is he had developed a
series of protocols on how to neutralize
each member of the Justice League so
with Superman it was exposing him to a
form of kryptonite that would make his
skin translucent and it would basically
lead to him being paralyzed with pain
because of the massive amount of solar
radiation being bombarded onto him right
because his skin serves as a kind of
filter her like having a shade over a
lamp that with the Green Lantern Kyle
Rainer it was taking away his eyesight
with Wonder Woman it was putting a
device in her head that would lead to
her seeing an enemy that wasn't there
and she would basically fight to the
death she would fight until her heart
gave out but the result to this is that
in the aftermath of Tower of Babel
Batman was voted out of the league
because they lost trust in him they
couldn't trust him anymore and so this
is kind of a follow-up conversation
where literally Superman asks him what's
your backup plan right like you have a
backup plan for the entirety of the
Justice League what's the backup plan
for Batman what's the backup plan for
the man who knows every move and his
response is it's you Superman he's like
no there's no way that's true because
you were able to overpower me you knew
exactly what I was going to do you knew
exactly what my weaknesses were and I
didn't know exactly what yours were so
what's the backup plan for the man who
has the answer to everything and the
answer is Fail-Safe that's literally the
answer to this now of course this wonky
crazy looking version of Batman there's
a reason why he looks like this right
this Batman refers to himself as the
Batman of zorinar now here's the thing
right understanding the Batman of xernar
it's it's kind of weird right so wind
the clock back to the 1950s right it's
Batman issue number 100 and something I
remember the issue number but basically
it was Silver age Batman anybody who
knows anything about Silver age Batman
will tell you that those Comics were
just a descent into total Madness but
that's where you were initially
introduced to Batman zorinar who was
technically the Batman of a different
world but basically had the powers of
Superman now fast forward to Grant
Morrison's run and Grant Morrison
basically wiped all that away and said
that the Batman of zurinar is the result
of what happened when Batman was exposed
to a mental attack and so the the
creation kind of the the manifestation
of Batman's ear and R is effectively a
version of Batman that manifests as a
kind of separate personality to protect
Batman from like psychic attacks but one
of the things that had happened here is
at least as it's being done here by chip
sadarski is that presumably in the
aftermath of the Tower of Babel's
storyline that Batman had created
Fail-Safe the Batman of xernar had
created failed safe and this was done
expressly because of the fact that if
Bruce Wayne himself had created
Fail-Safe then all somebody had to do
was figure out that Batman had done it
and then potentially attack him or
something along those lines but it could
be easily neutralized right by having
the Batman of zurinar create Fail-Safe
Bruce Wayne wouldn't actually remember
who failsafe was more so than that he
wouldn't remember how to overpower him
it's the perfect plan right he'll never
really be able to figure out exactly how
to take this thing down and that's
exactly what happens now the other thing
about Batman's are an R is he's kind of
an answer to the question what happens
when the brakes come off with Batman
right when he's far more ruthless more
aggressive when he doesn't really care
about the people around him when he's
kind of like the sociopathic Batman
that's what this guy is and notice this
a lot of this comes by way of the fact
that one he is far more aggressive in
his fight against uh Fail-Safe than
Batman traditionally would be right this
guy doesn't hold back Batman always kind
of holds back to a degree just because
of the fact that he doesn't really know
exactly how much energy he'll need to
use in a fight against an opponent so by
kind of rationing it out based on the
context of the situation it allows him
to fight longer in a more capable way
when it comes to somebody like Batman's
or an R he just goes balls in right he
just just goes nuts right just starts
attacking this guy you know with every
ounce of strength and and capability
that he has but again it's not enough
right it's not going to happen now the
other reason for why failsafe even
exists in the first place and that's one
of the big Revelations here is that with
the belief that Batman had killed Oswald
cobblepot that he killed the penguin
that Batman has simply gone too far and
that Fail-Safe activated as an answer to
the question what happens when Batman
goes off the rail who's going to stop
Batman when he finally starts killing
people and so that's why failsave is
here in the first place now one of the
funny things that happens is that Tim
Drake tries to rationalize with fail
statement say like Batman did not kill
Oswald cobblepot cobblepot killed
himself but it doesn't work right
because at the end of the day failsave
is operating on programming which is
Batman's gone too far and Batman has to
die now ultimately failsafe makes his
way to the old Gotham Manor I'm sorry
the Wayne Manor and then of course Bruce
Wayne and everybody basically follows
suit now technically they already kind
of knew he was going to to be going
there because Batman or at least Batman
is there an R had basically put a kind
of tracking device on failsafe but in
this fight one of the funny things that
happens is that because Batman is there
an R is so extreme here he doesn't see
the kind of familial connections that
come with the different members of the
bad family he sees them as soldiers
right that's what he is he's like
they're soldiers that's all they are and
so what it does is it kind of jumps to
the mindscape of Bruce Wayne so to speak
where you have the Bruce Wayne
personality that it handed control over
to Batman of xernar but Bruce Wayne's
kind of is teaching him and saying like
they're not soldiers right you are the
most pure version of Batman which is the
unadulterated unfiltered version of
Batman that will do whatever it takes to
defeat the enemy even things that I as
Bruce Wayne am not necessarily willing
to do but understand here these guys are
not soldiers Robin is not a soldier he's
basically my son right he's family and
you have to treat him that way and so
what it does is it seems to lead to
Bruce Wayne seemingly retaking control
of his body due to the realization that
while the Batman of xernar seems to have
the ability to take out failsafe that
the collateral damage would just be too
extreme that he would put the other
members of the bad family In Harm's Way
or even just callously disregard their
lives because he doesn't see them as
anybody meaningful and so what ends up
happening is Bruce Wayne basically sends
Tim Drake away and says you need to call
for help when your signal comes back
right because failsafe has the ability
to disrupt their Communications so he
literally says like go and get help when
you have it then come back and so in
this fight between the two again Bruce
Wayne is just overpowered because he
can't go toe-to-toe with this guy he
can't go toe-to-toe with Fail-Safe and
so in this moment when failsafe
literally gets the upper hand on Batman
and I mean just like pummeling this guy
beating on him like a side of beef right
like when he's literally about to kill
Batman on the spot there's this whoosh
that comes in from nowhere and whisked
Batman out of the way of this attack
right this guy just says I'm going to
need you to back away from my friend
only for us to find out Superman is here
ladies and Gentlemen Just Right son
Batman and Superman are facing off
against the anti-batman in the next
video yeah with that being said guys
Club hangers we're gonna bring this to
an end thank you all for watching I will
catch you all later peace